[موسيقى]
القرف
لم تكن طفولتي فارغة
الناس أن شخص ما سيكون عني
اعتني بنفسك كما قال لي جدي
أسوأ من الركل عندما لا
سيكون هنا قال إنه طمأنني
لقد جعلتني لحيتي أركض إليك
تيومين هذا الأمل فارغ
يُلزم ألكسندر بيلتسكي المقيم
فيري لاند وأخبر العاصمة
agarkova شخص ما يتزوج في الخارج
إلى دول أخرى
وتزوجت خارج حدود الواقع و
حكايات خرافية تسكن لأنني أصبحت
خسوف لم أعد أذهب إلى هذه الغابة وأنا
الآن ريفمان هو نفسه هاجريد
ربما هو نفس مصنع الأماكن
هنا يبدأ مسار قريتنا
حكايتنا الخيالية محددة الآن
اجاركوفا
ولكن إذا نظرت من الجانب الآخر
ثم يقول إله الأفواه هو آخر
جانب واقع آخر حتى تتمكن من ذلك
ادخلوا حقيقة واحدة واخرجوا نهائيا
من حياتي الأخرى كان هناك مثل هذا البلد
التي لم تعد ميدالية جائزة
الاتحاد السوفيتي ، إذا أرادوا ذلك
أكتوبر جيد جدا وانه بعد ذلك
رائد جيد جدا ، لكنه يستطيع فعل ذلك
اتضح أن هناك محاولات لجعلي
يا له من جندي جيد
لم ينجح الأمر أيضًا وأشعر بذلك
لقد فقدت بلا حدود أدركت ذلك
لا يمكنهم فعل ذلك بي ومن ثم لا بطريقة ما
بشكل طبيعي عندما كنت في بلدي
القرية الأصلية هذا كل شيء ، نعم ، كل شيء جيد
تشون omichki هنا رائع بالفعل
مدخل البوابة إلى قصتنا الخيالية في وسط أ
تحدث
ربع هو من تلك الحقيقة التي
يعتقد الناس أنها حقيقة
الحقيقة التي هي
حقًا يعطي حقيقة خرافية
نحن قادمون الآن قوارب سحرية
pizhanka هي سفينة قراصنة حقيقية بشكل جيد
قد لا ترى الآن ولكن أنا هنا
سأحصل على عصا سحرية
انظر وقل
تتحول إلى سفينة قراصنة
أخشى حتى الدخول إلى المدينة لأنني
إذا رأوني هكذا ، يمكنهم ذلك
أرسل للعلاج ، نعم ، سيفعلون
على طريقتهم الخاصة ، ها هم
مخلوق خرافية يجب أن كل شيء
كن واستلقي ثم تأكل عندما تدع
هناك مفاهيم يجب تركها وما هو جيد
المكان الذي أعيش فيه حيث نغتسل جميعًا الأطفال
فهم ليس لديه قرية فيها
نحن موجودون
ليس لديها جمهور
رسائل لا غاز لا لا يوجد بالفعل لا
الإدارة ليس لها رأي ثم المدرسة و
لا توجد أيام في المستشفى ولكن كل شيء للزوجة
ماذا تقول هذا معجزة أي نوع من الأحذية
قرية كريمة لدينا أيضا
توقف بشكل جيد على عكس أي شخص آخر
توقف أكثر من حافلة أبدًا
بقي بالقرب من هذا المكان و
حتى جامعي الفطر هؤلاء
من الآن يذهب هناك ويبكي وبعد ذلك
اجلس وانتظر للأسف أملهم
غير مجدي
لن يكون هناك أي حافلات
البدلة الأنيقة الوحيدة من هنا
هذا بابا ياجا وهي أيضًا على متن رحلات الطيران العارض
على مكنسة يمكن أن تأخذ مكان أكثر
أو داوليت في المحطات العامة
مثله
ظهر هاري بوتر سأقرأ
قرأت المنزل الأول ، فهمت ذلك بشكل عام
هذه ساشا تتحدث بلغة حديثة
بغل
أي أنها إعادة رواية
رئيس
لماذا نعيش من نحن ومن اين واين
لأنها لغة من ناحية
واضح
من ناحية أخرى فهو آمن
عميق جدا حقا
في متناول أي طفل للكثيرين
الكبار غير متاحين ، أنا لا أفهم ذلك
kodori إذن لعدم هاري بوتر
الخفاقة هي مجرد خفقت في مكان ما
يطير نعم هناك بعض المعجزات في مكان ما
آثار الفقر ولكن قراءة هذا الكتاب لك
لا تبقى غير مبال بها و
يبدو أن الناس يتحدثون نفس اللغة
لا نفهم بعضنا البعض ولكن هناك طريقة للخروج
أنا شخصيا وجدت أنها وجدت مثل هذه اللغة
الذي لا يتوفر غير واضح وعليه
ليس جيدًا للتواصل ، إنه أمر رائع
هذه الغرفة plax تشغيلها ثلاث مرات و
لا تأخذ الكتب هنا وبعد ذلك
تخمين ما هو عليه
هناك وانتظارك
[موسيقى]
نحن نعيش في وسط غابة كبيرة وغابة
يغذينا جميعا
في الغابة بشكل عام ترى ذلك تمامًا
كل نصل من العشب نبات القنفذ كل منهم
يعرفون كل ما ينقلون كل ما قيدت و
إنها عجائب لا نهاية لها
عندما تقول يا إلهي
لك وهناك مساعدة بمجرد أن يصبح ذلك غير ممكن
تحصل على مساعدة بالمال السحري
نحن لا نواجه أي مشاكل ، الحمد لله
لدينا الخاصة بهم ونقول هذا كل شيء
تقترب عمليات السرقة من نهايتها ويجب علينا ذلك
بعض الضرائب لا يزال هناك شيء لتقديمه
في مكان ما نقوم به
بشكل دوري لم يكن ينتهي
أورال القديمة هذه التقنية هي زوجي
أصبح من غير الضروري أنها قدمتها وسنتين لها
باع جرار شجرة التنوب سيارته الكبيرة جدًا
نقل جيد الذي أكل أيضا
حسنًا ، أنت لا تعرف حتى المقدار
أشياء منتشرة في جميع أنحاء العالم
يأتي الناس ودعونا نكون على الحافة
كذكرى سنشتري البعض
الشيء الذي فعلته هناك نعم هناك
أقوم بعمل مثل هذه الأقفال أو هذه هي الأكواب
جاء رجل دعني أيضا
مثلها ، نعم ، سأبيعها هنا تذهب ، تذهب
هكذا تعثر الحجر اللعين
الكذب أعتقد أي نوع من الأحجار مثل هذه الأبازيم
جرته هذا هو أساس الجدول هنا
أتت من مكان ما في هذا الرجل
طاولة الحجر بالفعل مين يأخذ على
يأخذ الحجر ويمنحك الكثير من المال
الاعتماد على المقياس ولكن هل هو
يبحث عنها مثل حجرهم وضع كومي فقط
نتعمق أكثر في الغابة
حيث الفطر التوت
[موسيقى]
على موقعنا عندما كنت تعيش في مقرر
عندما يغذي pontius يحمي الشفاء
يمنحك الفرصة ل
إبداع
وتستريح الروح وتفرح بما هو
تحت نمط أينما ذهبت
انتهينا من المشاهدة
كل شيء في الكوخ متناغم بل وأكثر
سقطت بعض الأغصان وخطبت
متخصصون في الغابات
سوف تطير الحشرات البق وروستوف
أصبحت المنازل بقطراتها الخاصة ، ولكن هنا
سيكون دائما دافئ جيد و
لخلق مثل هذه الراحة والجمال للإنسان
وعلينا بالفعل أن نحاول بسبب
له الأمر معقد
[موسيقى]
عندما نذهب للفطر نأخذ منه
الحقائب وجمع المزيد من العواقب
رحلات جامعي الفطر الآخرين أكوام القمامة
تنمو معنا بانتظام كل نفس
لسوء الحظ يأتي الرجل هنا من هنا
لجهلي ، هذه هي الأشياء ، لكن
ثم بابا ياجا بالاسم من كل منهما
أسأل أنا غطت على الفور لا على الفور
اسأل لماذا أنت هناك من العمل كله
الصحة السيئة كل شيء سيء وبشكل عام
لا يوجد حب وقد تم جلب القمامة إلى الغابة
ضعها كلها أو تعايش معها الآن
حتى تذهب لا تخرج من هناك بعد ذلك
ما وضعوه
[موسيقى]
الكثير من 6 مواقد في المنطقة
الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكننا القيام به هو لنا و
نقوم بتسخين الطعام هناك أعد الطائر
يمكنك الموافقة على أنها تطبخ نفسها
طعام ولا حاجة لتحريك شيء
مجموعة مزيج مرة واحدة فقط
سوف تطبخ لك بالتأكيد
ثم لا تزال دافئة عندما تعيش
الطبيعة ، فأنت تفهم ذلك كل يوم
هذه عطلة
مفهوم مثل الاثنين الثلاثاء
الاربعاء الخميس العلاج منفذ بيت الدواجن
خسرت أول شيء تخسره
اسماء ايام الاسبوع تختفي
ثم تختفي الأرقام اسم الأشهر
تختفي تبدأ في العيش ببطء
على نفس المنوال
ماذا يعيش بجوارك لو سأفعل
أفكر في إطار السنوات المفروضة هناك ، ثم أنا
سأفقد التل ولدي الإعدادات فقط
يجب أن يعيش الإنسان على سبيل المثال الآن بشكل جيد
65 عامًا وكل شيء يكفي أيضًا ، من هنا
من الأفضل عدم الخروج في المنزل ، لكن لا يوجد شيء من هذا القبيل
بارك الله فيك ، وسيمنحك الله الكثير ستعيشه
أنت حقا عمري الداخلي
انه قاصر بداخلي
أن تكون
يحتاج الناس إلى معرفة كيف يتجهون إلى ما يحتاجه الناس
بحاجة إلى إنشاء مراكز للتدريب الحرفي
كل شيء آخر لأن المصنع
الجمهور القريب
وحدة الرجل ولكن كان لدي مثل هذا السؤال
لقد كنت أحاول العثور على واحد مثل هذا لسنوات
مكان حيث يمكنك إنشاء هذا
مركز الابداع التعلم بجميع انواعه
التقنيات التقليدية
مثلك تبني منزلًا وكأنك تذهب به
في الجوهر ، هم ليسوا فقط
في المنزل ورشة كبيرة كبيرة حيث
السحرة والسحرة مكان فيه
يمكنهم القيام بسحرهم
الشيء يذهب في بعض الأحيان إلى 40
حول المعالجات في مختلف
توجيهات شخص ما لجرعة شخص ما
يجعل كل أنواع الأزياء الرائعة نعم
شخص ما يصنع كل أنواعه
على سبيل المثال ، هناك سيراميك أو غيرها
بعض منتجات التمثيل ولكن أي شيء
الذي يتم باليد هي من الواضح
لا يمكن أن تنافس هذا أيضا
صنع في مصنع أو مؤسسات
لأنها وضعت روحها فيه
انها تحتاج الى الكثير من الوقت تحتاج الى عمق
البعض بالتأكيد
كان عددًا لا حصر له من البطولات
محاولات معلمي مدرستي
اجعلني كذلك مع النظام الذي أقف عليه
يجب أن يكون ترسًا في بعض الأنظمة
إنه يعلم أن الأمر لم ينجح
ليس مع عيوبي بمظهري
على الأشياء و
وقدرات ، أدركت ما هو
المكان الوحيد في قصة خيالية
قالها انه يثير النهي
محجوزة للغابات والعيش واضح لي
أطفال سيف البيئة عضويون للغاية هنا
مثل هذه الكلمة ظهرت أحجار الراين العضوية
بالإضافة إلى ذلك
هنا سيبقى مرتديًا خوذة وها أنا
فقط أكل طائرتك
فماذا كذلك في أي رجل
يبحث عن إجابة لسؤال شخص ما من أين و
إلى أين أنت ذاهب بهذه الإجابات؟
لم تتم صياغتها لفظيًا ، لكن لا
الشعور لكنه قال أيضا أن هذا الشعور هو أنا
أفهم من وأين سأذهب وماذا أنا أيضًا
ربما يمكنني أن أحضر
لماذا أنا مثل كل مخاوفي
صوامع مثل نحن كسالى جدا ولدينا صغير
أنا ناجح بالنسبة لي حيث كل شيء واضح
واضح وواضح
[موسيقى]